欢迎回来 希望你已经安装了 GHC
也尝试了一下输入表达式
现在要从简单表达式更进一步
看看如何将整个Haskell 程序载入 GHC 中
在 Haskell 中 程序并不叫程序
通常人们称代码为
脚本
因为 Haskell 的程序比通常的代码短
我通常就叫程序
但 Haskell 的说法是脚本
如果你想定义一个完整的程序
可以将他们定义在
一个含有函数列表的文本文件中
这一文本文件
后缀是 .hs 表示
它是一个 Haskell 文件 好比 HTML 文件
后缀名是 .html CSS 文件后缀名是 .css
或者 Java 文件
后缀名是 .java
Haskell 文件是以 .hs 结尾的
虽然不是必须这样
但很有用 当你查看文件夹时
就可以看到这是一个 Haskell 脚本文件
使用 GHC 时
要做的是在一个窗口用一个文本编辑器编辑脚本
做出改变后  将脚本重新载入 GHC
再开始执行表达式 你在课程中主要用到的
工作流就是这样 对于简单的应用
这样就够了 当然如果要写商业性的程序
就不会这样了
你会将脚本编译成为可独立执行的文件
但这们课程中 我们只需要前面的方式
一边开着编辑器的窗口 另一边开着 GHCi 解释器的窗口
接下来载入脚本
这个例子中
我们新建一个名为 test.hs 的文本文件
编写两个函数 第一个是求二倍函数
double 也就是 x + x 顾名思义
下一个是求四倍函数 quadruple 在 double x 上调用 double 实现
保存文件
用 test.hs 做参数运行 GHCi
现在 Haskell 标准库和 test.hs 中定义的 quadruple 与 double
都可以用了 比如我们调用
10 的四倍
返回值是 40
同时仍然可以使用标准库函数 比如
可以从列表取 2 的二倍个元素 2 的二倍是 4 相当于取 4 个元素
因此从列表中取到了 4 个元素
现在保持 GHCi 开启 回到编辑器窗口 添加
两个新定义 一个是阶乘 另一个是均值 因为我们刚刚开始
这里用到了一些还没学过的语法
所以请忍一下 阶乘是从 1 到 n 的乘积 这里的
是 1 到 n 的列表
product 是一个标准库函数
作用是取得列表中元素乘积
这个定义实现了阶乘 接下来定义一个列表的均值
首先求元素的和 接下来除以列表的长度 当然这并非一个求均值的好实现
但现在并不重要
我们并非要定义均值 而是要学 GHCi 的使用
这里用到的技巧是 当你在 Haskell 中
将一个函数的名字放在两个单反引号中间时
就将它作为一个中缀操作符
写 x `f` y 实际上就是语法糖
f x y 一些人喜欢用中缀操作符
另一些喜欢普通的方法
你可以自己选择 因此这里是一个语法规则 而非字符串或是别的
它将一个函数转换为中缀操作符
在 GHCi 中我们用 :reload 重新加载
它将读入 test.hs 文件 添加新定义的名字绑定
也就是 factorial 因此可以在这里调用 factorial
也可以调用 average
请看这里的工作流程 保持 GHCi 窗口开启 进入编辑器
进行编辑 重新加载 接下来可以试试你写的代码了 一些 Haskell 中的
特殊的语法规定 函数名和参数名必须以小写字母开头
可以用这样的形式定义函数 但开头必须小写
可以在名字中用普通英文引号
如果你懒得取新名字的话
这也是我在其他语言中想念的特性 我想写 x 撇 x 两撇等等
如果定义一个类型 首字母需要大写 因此才会这样
Haskell 中类型和标识符在不同的名字空间中 这是用
首字母大小写来区分的
来自其他编程语言背景的人可能很困惑
比如 Java C# 和 JavaScript.
另一件事是 Haskell 中常用一种较弱的匈牙利命名法
如果参数以 s 结尾 比如 xs ns 或 nss
表示它们是 x 类型值的列表 n 类型的值的列表 有时 n 并不对应于
类型名 但通常看到名字中的 s 就知道它是个列表了
如果结尾有两个 s
就代表一个列表的列表
这是一个惯例 如果想要看起来像真正的 Haskell 程序员一样
你应该采用这一惯例 如果参数是一个列表
就应该用 s 结尾 通常 Haskell 标识符很短
因此不叫它 elements 而叫 xs
另一个和 Python 相同的有趣之处是
空白是有意义的
准确的规则很繁琐
因为我们只用 Haskell 中很简单的部分
知道这些就够了 如果有一系列的定义
应在同一列起始
a, b 和 c 都在同一列起始 这边 b 左侧有空格
因此定义没有从相同列起始
就出错了 这边的 c 和 a 没有和 b 在同一行起始也错了
Haskell 中的空白是有意义的
确保定义对其 这叫 布局规则
布局规则是为了避免不必要的语法
Haskell 程序员喜欢这样写 a = b + c where
在 where 子句中 我们有一系列的定义
它们以同一行起始 d 和 a 在同一行起始
因此和 a 属于同一组
你可以这样显式地写出来
用花括号和分号
但看起来太过啰唆 Haskell 程序员喜欢简洁
因此经常使用有意义的空白
这种写法略显笨拙
如果你在 Haskell 中这样写代码 人们就会说
你没做足那些训练
这是一些有用的 GHC 命令
强烈建议你试验一下 当你做
接下来几课的练习时 确保利用好
GHC 或其他的编译器的帮助
我们看过了 reload 也可以用 load
载入一个新脚本
可以从解释器里打开编辑器
编辑特定文件 或者当前文件
这个命令很有用
它给出表达式的类型 我经常使用
我从不自己写类型 因此把表达式从编辑器粘贴到这里问一下类型
用 :? 命令得到所有可用命令的列表
和简短的解释 当然
我希望你 不要 用最后这个命令退出 GHC
但最后你还是要用的 接下来的八周将经常用 GHC
网站上将有很多练习
你可以用任何语言完成这些练习 不一定非要用 GHC
但既然本讲讲的是 GHC 对应的练习也是针对 GHC 的
一般而言 正如我在第一节课中所说的
这是一门函数式程序设计课 而非 Haskell 课 更不是 GHC 课
但本章的练习是关于 GHC 的 因为课程内容是 GHCi
祝你 Hacking 愉快 下周再见！